so I kept going and then aunt went
stopped you're awful awesome and then
Alonzo Bodden goes get the hill of the
stage yes klonopin Kirkman I remember a
comedy scene in the 2000s yeah he also
sells the hip Dunlop amputated diabetes
feet it's kind of like asking a woman to
marry you she says no the FPGA at her
wedding Oh some of these flash pots next
to all these Kleenex boxes and kerosene
what is fault I feel like it's a club's
fault well it's they should have been
setting off pyro and that's small right
you know what I thought you should know
better do you know Kozak the magician
Kozak you know the exact I worked with
him at foo bars back in the 90s remember
them food bars and I was uh he opens his
show he goes up he walks on stage of
this crazy music but I but a thrill
Vegas and there's it's it's really small
there's like 80 people in this tiny room
if you remember fubar barely uh tiny
like in a mini mall and he goes up in
the first thing he says his close your
eyes and then he ignites this flash
paper mass in his hand and it's blinding
and everybody goes at they sheer and
then they go guys they're blinking away
these UFOs I told you to close your eyes
but the thing is he would do it and you
would see dust and cobwebs on this on
the ceiling of the club like kind of
like you're gonna get this whole place
burned down and Irina i worked with
Kozak in austin texas did he open with
the yeah absolutely and he did all the
like jump jive type swing music and i
was taken out by the owner of the local
strip club he would send a limo for all
the comics there were eight strippers in
there and they all were making out night
is just sitting there is like 22 I
didn't know what to do he goes son
always pull your dick out this is a bit
of advice out of the top hat yes I'm
connect the magician and see what
happens behind your ear it's in my penis
bang like I'd like to deposit it I guess
it go that's how David Copperfield's get
in trouble oh look did you say did you
see pull his dick out closer ah I can't
believe it the middle pulls dick out am
I gonna end on now you gotta do a song
XD hey will you close with cuz i get my
dick out let's get this puppy going
alright rolling all right thanks for
tuning in again once again to road
stories I'm of course your host Murray
valeriano sitting across the table from
me as usual the very reliable i can say
after this week joe wilson why reliable
well because i lost my phone i lost my
phone on the 10 freeway and some guy
picks it up it's in five pieces he puts
it together hits the redial button Joe's
numbers on it he's like hey I found this
phone so Joe writes down the guys number
gets in his car drives to my house and
gives it to my wife because I don't know
any other number and I knew he was
pacing somewhere go where the [ __ ] is my
phone meanwhile I was actually surfing I
had no idea I lost my wife on the other
hand throw it out the window on the
freeway no I got out to check my car
idling and knocked my phone out I
thought I just left it at home so cut to
six hours later seven eight hours later
i come home my wife after Joe drops off
this note saying uh yeah you your your
husband's phone is missing well dropped
it on to her so it's not like yeah she
just came up and found a note she thinks
I'm dead Oh like nine hours and so I
come home not dead and she's having a
party yeah she was remarried it was the
witness this is awkward but this is this
is a victory it's only been ten oh honey
come on I had to move on join us today
but anyway thank you so much for that
Joe joining us today you know I'm from
premium blend mind of mencia late Friday
a good friend of mine funny comedian
blaine capatch hi everybody he Blaine
Blaine and across from him is the very
lovely very pretty rich williams you
thought he was going to Zig I thought
it's gonna dig but I zagged comedy come
next time even lovely
in prettier almost said funnier and got
my ass kicked trillium jen kirkman
joining us tonight hi jen at the
valeriano wilson podcast studios in
lovely downtown Los Angeles California
this is Toluca lack I'm getting to look
a lack adjacent are you two look alike
is are you living hey guys feel it
Melissa no los feliz cuz i pronounce it
correctly I do too but I think these
felis not to not intimidate other people
yeah I know yeah gyroid euro yeah i
strictly go how it's spelled yeah yeah
well it that a gyro that's guy all those
feels right that's like if there's a G
in it right let's vilas yeah G is silent
like in swimming pool easy my friend who
went to Japan and then came back and was
like sake instead of sake and I'm like
but no one said just say it like we say
I went to England sorry general no
that's it I went to kingsland another
thing about the Brits with a girl who is
of English descent and picked up the
English language like that all is that
were they they barely lay into the
airport and she's like so we go on
fatigue oh yeah what no you live in New
Jersey what are you talking like that
but then three days later I picked up
the English accent it's a very easy
Axman Donna and Guy Ritchie mmm do you
it's like I know he is English it's like
working with Lord corette have you ever
worked with Lord carell yeah yeah he's
one of those guys were at the end of the
week you find yourself doing your act in
his delivery right one of those guys
that has the where you absorb their uh
their complete personality and then
become them and get their pin number
Brody Stevens I want to do his accent or
his uh cadence when I'm around him yeah
he is very easy he's addictive yeah I'll
be 30 mins culver city perhaps you've
heard of it wow i have i got brody a job
at best damn sports show as the warm-up
guy now you yeah and he was suspended so
many times he wore a sweatshirt that
said HNIC
head blank in charge and stuff and
everybody he we yell he would yell at
the makeup girls shut up I'm trying to
entertain a micro to your the warm up
comic and then he lasted longer than
everybody else that was there oh yeah
he's he's still doing it I read the only
is he still doing it yeah okay I saw him
I doing warm up for the man show a
couple of times and he would just go out
there who wants a t-shirt sure over here
nice pitch ma'am uh and he would just
get him wild just waving shirts over his
head I did warm up i don't i hope i
didn't tell this story on the show
before but i did warm up for mtv where
nobody comes to California to see him TV
shows so they have to buy their audience
it's just out-of-work actors making 50
bucks to sit in the audience and it was
four episodes they're cheap for game
shows a day which is relentless long so
I made a deal with the audience Emily
alright if you guys laugh when I say
laugh scream when I say scream yell when
I say L I won't make balloon animals
sweet so that's a painful gag man
anybody ever done it yeah I have four
Last Comic Standing all of the seasons I
got fired one season because I was
writing for the comics I didn't know was
against the rules and so I had
auditioned the second season or no the
first season they said you're not right
for the show can you do audience warm up
for the real comics it's kind of like
asking a woman to marry you she says no
then you have to DJ at her wedding they
look like they're having a great time I
got tricked into auditioning for that
this year which I vowed I never would
what Last Comic Standing and after you
thought you're going in for comics
unleashed haha I got no I mean they it
was like the producer chennai hear you I
hear you have a mother tell us about it
I hear you have a mother and she talks
like this thanks Byron they're good you
could the comics be less unleashed on
this show if you think about it because
they're just there to do their material
set up to do there yeah yeah so it's not
like look
out where's it gonna go it's gonna go
like they're opening five minutes yeah
so how did you get trick the producer
lady called me and she's like look I
know you probably wouldn't do it but
this season no one's gonna live in the
house and we know all the women on the
show been awful but I'm really familiar
she's like I'm really familiar with the
comedy scene and I know you and she
named like every person that I know and
she's like I really like this kind of
comedy and you should do it i'm totally
in charge it's gonna be very different
this year i got you an audition you just
go in i'll know who you are like just
made it seem like it was gonna be easy
she's like the worst thing that's gonna
happen is you're not going to get a call
back and then that's it and then no harm
done and she said if you want anything
cut out just call me and I won't put you
on the episodes where they show people
getting cut and great all right I go in
and it's the improv which I feel very
comfortable there and it's totally
uncomfortable and the microphone was
rigged with this weird clip that nobody
ever would use so you immediately start
fumbling and I did my first joke which
is a tried and true joke I've done on
the road done it forever it makes people
laugh big old case we didn't we didn't
get that from the beginning of the
discouraged yeah always i use an
unbroken constantly it makes people
laugh it entertains people I'm but then
they all were just staring at me like
they were angry and what's-her-name
Kathleen Madigan started to raise her
hand and do some weird thing and I
thought she was doing like an amen and
that I was like so I kept going and then
aunt went stop you're awful ha ha and
then Alonzo Bodden goes get the hell of
the stage yes and so I but I couldn't
hear them so I was like so I just went
what and then I heard aunt go again
awful bye and I went oh ok I'm a weird
and Alonzo goes why do you think we were
holding our hands up do you think we
were testifying and I went kind of and
then I just walked walked out and called
the woman who went what the f [ __ ] was
that and then she was like I'm so sorry
that shouldn't have happened I don't
know what happened and then she called
Kathleen maghuin and Kathleen was like
well we just didn't think she was good
and we had a question for her that's why
our hands are up I'm like who takes
questions yeah after their opening joke
oh gosh I push I don't I don't
understand how how you can put those
people in a position to quantify
something and so unquantifiable you know
it's you got an out there making
judgment calls right it's it's begging
for it it's begging for it on your hands
and knees yeah it's all I cannot believe
I just thought it would be we're all in
on that I just was totally tricked and I
went home and I really felt sick for a
day felt like I'd been I really felt I
got you got set up many Sucker Punch
yeah yeah you know that that's the thing
that that's so weird about comedy is
like it's it's everybody on a show is
supposed to serve the show you know what
I mean everybody's supposed to you're
supposed to entertain the audience
mm-hmm I hate to get all you know
Marxist about it but uh it's you're
supposed to you know you want to sell
drinks you want to get hired again you'd
want you want people to like you all
that stuff and if you go up there and
you start comparing well he's not funny
he's not as funny as she is she we had a
week opener bachina once you start doing
that kind of stuff it takes all the fun
out of it and it's it's it's it just
makes it poisonous I think it's like
those this I did the comedy competition
in San Francisco couple years and both
times it's like why are my feet sweating
when I've done nothing wrong all I did
was five Riley did was five in my feet
are sweating and I can't sleep it's a
wireless people comics love comedy I
mean even if you have a competitiveness
inside of you like they didn't watch it
with a sense of joy and I think the show
would be just as interesting cuz you're
still gonna have crazy people off the
street that have never done it you're
still going to have maybe a professional
who bonds like interesting things will
happen yours have to trust that they
don't have to be mean to get it rolling
yeah but particularly yeah I did the LA
comedy festival with Dante and Jay
London both of thank you very much
graduating and Jay London makes me laugh
and I don't know if I'm laughing at him
or with him because anybody who
apologizes constantly for sucking while
they're sucking I say yay yes really
amazing but rights make a left Dante is
you know the headliner and because he's
been doing stand-up comedy for 21 years
and he his opening bid is how Last Comic
Standing [ __ ] up a joke in the editing
that's a great opener you know what
audiences love to hear about
post-production it's very relatable
really yet really great and totally
crushed couple of discs so final cut
last file cutters and he's wearing a
t-shirt this is famous stand-up comic Oh
is there a question mark at the end or
no no yes and no irony either well it
probably was pretty wrinkled I have two
quick short stories about Last Comic
Standing the first season they were
airing the worst of the worst and he
thought this was going to be great it's
like oh yeah I don't know yeah and
nobody in the live audience was laughing
Barry cats who's one of the executive
producers turns me goes I don't
understand why this isn't working I said
nobody wants to see a comic do poorly it
makes yer I comfortable show the best of
the rest should everybody who auditioned
has at least one good joke yeah they
never I did yeah the interesting thing
about the worst of the worst is a few of
they weren't bad knowing of them were
good colleagues they were just set up
you know like Jen was in a to blank
staring Booker's and they made him look
bad but that I would say I'm from what i
can remember i can remember five good
comics off the top of my head that were
in the worst of the worst quote-unquote
and they're good comics oh well I you
see jen kirkman and that who oh yeah why
guys okay i said i could only I didn't
see it one of the lights is out I felt
uncomfortable the whole next day after
singer dammit feet were sweaty for told
me they cut this not on the internet and
doing warm-up we also i had the
adornment for last comic for all the
seasons oh wow so i had to go backstage
and ask each comic in the final ten each
week when i was pared down what they
were going to talk about so that I as
the warm-up would not bump in any other
jokes and the most considerate warm-up
ever yeah well they made me do it though
I wanted to burn some of these people
but uh I went up it was right before dad
fan was going to go out who won season
one unbelievably that the bar extremely
high is the supreme court decision 54
yeah I heard he's asian yeah and he has
a crazy mom fox news called that he won
before
so I go up to bury cats and I have the
printer I go there there's a major
problem and he's literally about to go
on he was what what's the matter I said
everybody's act printed out fine but
that fans printed without any punch
lines he looks at me and he goes shut
the [ __ ] good out of your the warm-up
guy question for you though you said
that you wrote for some of them on the
show I didn't know that that happened
well I they did a roast for jay mohr and
so I wrote for a couple of comics but I
was not embarrassed about it and like I
didn't know that it was against the
rules yeah yeah I what was it against
the rules yeah I guess cuz i worked for
the show technically even though i was
independent contractor and i was a
conflict of fun tourist yeah I guess it
does bring some sort of weird FCC yeah
game show yeah 21 now you're gonna get
busted doing this no I know that they
didn't write their own stuff Oh dad fan
didn't some other asian guy so you go
dear do you go pretty far back with jay
mohr uh well just through the series oh
just there oh yeah okay cuz there's a
this house in Hollywood where like jay
mohr Ralphie May Josh wolf that was that
next to Dave Raths place up in the hills
cuz wrath lived with Poe sane and uh
Allen Allen Funt Allen fire yeah hi they
kicked him out rings they were doing he
had a camera in the urinal yeah that a
urinal in their apartment Todd glass
Dave wrath Brian Posehn and next door it
was jay mohr and i think mark cohen and
i don't know if that was the same house
because i went to a party at Jay Moore's
house and i watch Marc Cohn walk into a
glass sliding door and leaves like the
the face print on it like a bird hitting
a window it was horrible to laugh at but
I left really hard at it I could have
killed them explains what all that fog
is coming over the hills man would just
be that pot smokers to hell yeah that
place was like going to uh we scratch
perry's house no this is before i guess
they made it up to the hills
was behind this mexican restaurant no
that's not the waiters dealt drugs and
oh wait that is what yeah so yeah what
jetties nah chilis over there on Sunset
chevys jellies use call the whole thing
oh do we have to pay for that yes yeah
yeah no probably do there's a knock off
all right it was a parody oh it's a
parody you covered how was your band
stool you're not the buck sadhaks
anymore Blaine's in a no isn't a buck
sadhaks and then that broke up right
yeah we're now we're in the I'm in with
Tulsa skull swingers oh right right with
Craig Anton and Ron Lynch and meat
Eagleman I think we're playing wednesday
at midnight at tex restaurant they're
making some documentary about weird
bands in LA and apparently we're closing
it oh really nice hmm so you're going to
do your hands in LA yeah this one miss
alair in January so don't expect a big
turnout from our listeners well Oh in
January well I think we're gonna be
appearing at the crazy where I go casino
and exchange for this announcement you
know how the the internet it's kind of
slow it takes a while to get these
things up so yeah yeah that's so we
won't be on strike when this is on it
will be on sit right yeah still be
unscrewed who knows it's especially slow
since Joe's built a double iced latte
protection board it was it one shot
venti eggnog latte it's a lot of nog
dude you sure you okay to drive yes
you're pretty nog I have any nogs my
holding up to yeah man you're knocked up
do you know [ __ ] hows about your CD
selling Jen oh wow let's start out with
some sales figures wanna plug your CDL
help right actually I'm it's now it's
available digitally on itunes and other
I don't know what the [ __ ] it's called
but there's just digital where you can
get the road stories podcasts yes also
on itunes and I'm noticing people from
other countries are buying it digitally
which I find it fascinating I don't know
why or how but it is happening they
probably think it's actual self help I
wonder how many people that it's going
ok it's harder to sell I try to bring it
on
wrote of me and sell it and it feels
like I have a lemonade stand it's pretty
embarrassing right and then um I think
it sounds okay I mean I can't complain
have you thought of t-shirts I don't
want to make any more waste product in
America balls you can juggle with your
treatment beer cozies I'm trying to get
back with my wife i buy the CD it's all
about black water well this is black
water I think it's going as well as can
be expected it could be better what most
people I know don't buy it but other
people i don't know buy it which is nice
what goes into recording a comedy
seating oh well you might want to ask
someone who doesn't right but i did a
specific thing where i was asked to be
kind of the first a comedy record in
this series of comedy records and I I
didn't have to do anything except show
up and perform like the sky Matt bell
net he did all the sound and then
editing and everything so I just did all
the stuff that I thought represented
where I was at at that time and I did it
you know actually I did it I tried to
keep everything on one theme and I did
it more like a big long 45-minute story
is the self-help theme kind of yeah like
my fears there's some I don't really
know why it's called stuff up but you
know like fears and all kinds of crazy
things that I have going on my head and
so I did that so it's sort of like I
wanted it to feel like what a night at
this upright citizens brigade theater
would feel like if you happen to be
there that night seeing me it's not
quite like my greatest hits and let me
give it to a Booker so he gets a sense
like I think it might scare people off
in that way but I use it wasn't one
straight yeah our set or however long
you just did it once and yep nothin true
how it goes is that what's going into
distribution yeah I edited some stuff
out I cuz i get if i get comfortable
with the audience I start telling them
everything and I start going off on
tangents and so I edited out the
tangents because they could be worked on
made him to better things it's three
minutes long I just come out and then I
go so felt and then I run out and then
there's been a black water and then
there's an album so how do you deal with
the I know from reading your blog flying
not your number one activity how do you
do with that road
I have my fear of flying is gone now oh
it is I am the opposite I am in an exit
row I know Ryan I ever come she bought
the self-help yeah why am I unmedicated
I am in the exit row offering to help
I'm like pumped and ready I'm like a
ghost before on klonopin asleep crying
with a stuffed animal and now it's like
totally did you get hypnotized I just
had to fly every week for 10 weeks and
then I just after the second week I was
like I'm so tired from all these drugs
and I have a feeling that I'm okay if
you take drugs long enough on a flight
your body starts to reap so now i have
the relaxation response to flying
because I've drugged myself so many
times so it's just natural that responds
with driving i'm happy if i'm drunk or
not I'm just weaving everywhere I was
backing into kids I want to get up on
the mic on an airplane and give a speech
like everybody who might be afraid like
come talk to me so going on the road and
buy my CD self-help it cured me and now
I love it like I'm going to chicago this
weekend another crude story ever yeah
i'm like i can't wait to get on the
plane cuz no one can bother me it's just
awesome especially jetblue you watch TV
i am i am still of the heavily medicated
flying and I'm not taking any chances I
exactly I agree with that too I take a
little bit i take a little half of one
just oh wait i know the cheerleader what
happened to mr. she's doped up here's
the thing jacked up on goofballs my
anxiety is so intense that a half a
milligram of klonopin is is nothing it's
like I could take it right now until
around town it then that might not be
going medan ya reckon oh yeah don't take
come on a bit less prescribed by a
physician but I used to take like four
or five pills and like I mean and I
would still be panicking so I mean I
take a little bit just just so that no
physical stuff starts to happen like the
beating heart and I mean fast feeding i
started my heart from beating
palpitations I think five the ANA pins
might make your heart I've never taken
klonopin
is it I can't even take five yeah if I
took five i would i would be on a
website somewhere and the tragic death
oh no they're not magic related they're
happening so it's only 2.5 milligrams
and he is indestructible I'm bigger than
you so it you probably couldn't take fun
how much you were nuts everybody all
right Indian leg wrestle on the floor
right now well I'm capatch jen kirkman I
i I've been trying to gain weight cuz
I'm cuz I'm losing weight I'm already
thin I'm I'm just getting I'm just thin
I'm a thin guy and it bums me out
because I look gaunt because I'm getting
older and so I've tried to eat as much
as I can during the day and I and I
can't seem to stay over 113 what
Metallica's how much I weighed when I
was 16 eat late at night why do i do
made 113 when i was 4 i'm so jealous if
I we'd 113 I would look so good in
certain outfits so do i but then i have
to put on my man clothes and go out I'm
just trying to get into my wife stuff
wow what do you do are we taping no
other team and I'm trying to but it's
it's like I I just I'm trying to eat I'm
trying to eat what's your weight what's
your weight gain food what are you going
to you know what I'm trying to here's
the thing is I was I was a fast food
freak i was always eating fast food it
was like it was a comfort thing I grew
up with it and so but uh but I'm getting
to that thing where sometimes I get like
like short of breath I don't want to be
the the magic heart attack guy so I'm
trying to get rid of the fast food and
I'm trying to eat better so I eat like
last what I think was last week I eat so
much meat that I got gout almost you
know that we're a weird food hangover
we're like you have burning I blanks and
gigantic yeah it's it was you know its
verge of doubt kind of thing where
people over do it quick food you should
drink those uh smoothies from jamba
juice that are called like mousse or
whatever they're like 800 calories it's
like chocolate peanut butter banana you
know I just drink the the odwalla soy
shakes
okay that's probably too healthy you
should click weight gainer yeah that is
stuff like GNC brutal the [ __ ]
leaders muscle milk earlier that'll help
you and we'll be back with comedians
diets is coming on top of the hour
desserts how do you do it on the road
hey here's uh here's here's a weird
story on the here's an on-the-road story
at a comedy condo yes I was working at
Charlie good nights in raleigh north
carolina carolina back in the 80s and I
was it was me I was I was the emcee the
the headliner was killer bees Oh killer
bees he's kind of like a Jeff Foxworthy
cross with David Allan Coe like the the
bad boy version of Jeff Shaw so they're
really really racist Jeff Fox's yeah
super racist but you know like with the
might be a [ __ ] redneck if you hate
black people yeah exactly and you know
like more of a mullet he was a cool guy
and racist yeah wait I don't know what
state was raised but he was much more he
was more of a more of a caricature of a
southern könig Milan and his big thing
with save up you know Savea he would
like he'd tell a joke and tell a joke at
the beginning the crowd laughing no no
no save up save up they tell another
joke and it said let no no save up and
that so you got to the point where after
every joke the crowds going save up they
carry him out on their shoulders and
stuff these Pharaoh to them uh but it
was me and killer bees and this guy uh
Jeff Sweeney did you ever work with Jeff
Sweeney I know economics names Sweeney
yeah I get my Sweeney's confused like my
Baldwin's yeah it's why I don't think it
was one vat of Sweeney this is a
separate Sweeney but this guy we all got
in the car and went to the Piggly Wiggly
because we were gonna be there for like
tuesday through sunday so we go to the
Piggly Wiggly and we're all doing our
shopping and Jeff Sweeney got a I guess
what's 15 of them because we were there
for five days or whatever he got 15
microwave baked stuffed potato and one
for breakfast one for lunch one for
dinner every day he had two pairs of
pants you wore a pair of pants around
the haute
around the condo and then he had two
shirts and he would iron his pants and
his show pants and a shirt before the
show show pants yeah the chopin gasps
and I sit don't touch Mike show pants
where is losing my big toe potatoes
believe me dude nobody was near baked
stuffed potatoes and then killer killer
bees would go hi uh you want to help me
I'm going down in the mall and we would
just smoked pot go them all talk about
how much we hated him at his big stuff
that would then we found out that's a
bad comedian diet thing right but here
is the thing about Jeff Sweeney he said
that he was a dis off-the-cuff
conversation he was saying yeah well you
know I was doing a like a Sobel tour
like a comedy caravan for Tom Sowell a
bunch of dates around the Midwest or
whatever and I got to this one city and
the the gig was cancelled so I had a
warrant for mine outstanding warrant so
I turned myself in stay there for the
weekend and then I had you know that way
I didn't have to go back and he used his
his outstanding jail time to cover the
fact that needed a room while he was in
towns gig got canceled oh it was the
weirdest thing cuz he was he said he was
technically homeless he just lived on
the road he would have gig to gig with
his pants chopin's in his and his ghost
of potatoes and his outstanding warrants
the only joke I could remember he did is
he does it he ever get so drunk we just
put your foot in the toilet piss down
your leg great save it save save save oh
is he on myspace request him immediately
the flip side and I can't remember the
name of the comic but not very good he
tell a joke nothing would happen and he
would you stand like a take your time
yeah that's my new opener oh we were in
a comedy condo do you guys know Robert
Hawkins yeah yeah a famous scientist
Stephen I totally killed Julie talented
Usos isn't a guitar no I think it's
screamin Jay Hawkins Ronnie Hawkins you
know what these comedy condos there's
never any decor it's always just blank
walls it's so miserable so he and I went
to salvation army and
bought these like old 1970s portraits of
these girls and just put them up and it
free comics out for years to come it's
like it look like Runaways what the hell
did you guys do know there was a comedy
condo in uh it's for slap sticks in
Baltimore did you ever work slider work
Baltimore and they it was a nice place
at this place that overlooked the inner
harbor you can see the aquarium and the
submarine and stuff and a geeky guy
punched a hole in the wall hold on hold
on I'm going on record by saying this is
the second geeky guy reference on road
stories okay that's amazing I can tell
eet guy stores i DG guy punched a hole
in the wall this is before sharpie so he
took a ballpoint pen and circled it a
bunch of times and then wrote Geechee
guy did this and because Geechee guy did
that the the club owners came up and
yanked the phone out of the wall so that
nobody would have any phone privileges
which also meant you couldn't buzz
people in or out is gross but thanks
Keith Thank You chief wow way to go keep
an eye on this hole I'm sorry I'm sorry
if I keep babbling no no I was sitting
in an airport airport uh weirdo tying it
all together English to call back I'm
sitting at the airport and this is one
beat the geeks was on all the time I and
this Wayne former host to beat the geeks
in comedy I was I was Jake Ethan's
driving this woman sees me and I see her
see me and I know she knows that I'm
somebody and she comes over somebody or
no I know she knows that I'm whatever
and she comes over she goes she's
smiling useful hi hi she's looks like I
really hate to bother you uh this goes
sound weird are you Geechee guy oh and I
said no I'm not but I know who he is
well she goes oh my god I'm so sorry and
then she walks away and she stops at
sure smexy goes I don't know what's
weirder the fact that I thought you were
geeti guy or that you knew who GG guys
and then she shakes her head and walks
away what does he look like I have no
idea to call she is I have no idea that
you get Joe do you know get you guys I
don't know her legendary I've heard of
them Richard I said ma'am don't be sorry
I'm not kichi guy
no he should have said it and who I make
that out to thank you why yes I am DG
guy just got rid of the chiles do I'm
sure yet really we got to have him on he
got he's like I he said he's a legendary
guy and he's one of those guys where
he's had he's no Geechee GE e CH why
it's not his real name it's Weiss Weiss
why he's never been on Letterman because
I he won't use his real name what and
they roll won't brother Theodore they
won't calm Geechee guy well let me ask
each a guy maybe it was it tonight show
i was i'm not sure i'll have to have to
google it and snopes it dad google
snopes cross yes oeg factor Wow maybe
that's why I haven't been on there
tonight shadow they don't like my name
marie villarreal mary had a great name I
nobody can pronounce it murrayville
ariana except Blaine Blaine and me can
pronounce it it rhymes a must Murray
valeriano yeah valeriano no no I guess
it just rolls it rolls no but it got so
really got so bad I had to hack my name
down to Marie V because people can
pronounce it and they would just marites
good too maybe yeah man I sound like a
[ __ ] yeah you sound like Tony like it
hey hey don't make me and my brothers
come out there and kick your ass if you
don't laugh at my jokes you know really
the only podcast where you can smell the
Cologne what about Marie Valeri you bide
your car Marie Valeri now that rhymes or
mari Valerie thank you son Eric Murray
male marivel ah that's what my dude was
like Jerry Vale yeah maryvale and the
seeds ah speaking of maryvale I saw a
Nutty Professor last night buddy love
the original 94 in the original agent
husband Jerry Lewis was so shiny is so
shiny they didn't have anybody working
makeup everybody was so shiny they look
like they didn't powder them down no
power all man shut the love this Jerry
Lewis movies when I was a kid and like a
cinderfella and that's really don't know
what I can remember you from them and
who might never saw any well I like that
Jerry Luke I just I hated I the Stooges
and Jerry Lewis as a kid I hated them
now I hate them i clear not the band the
Stooges oh the Nor'easters yeah I
learned to three stooges in others and
I've been and I've been accused of being
gay because i hate this too
and the it was a cute quadruple shot
eggnog latte not helping it was accusing
you the guy whose penis was in your
mouth hello all my fear welcome to my
roast my theory of the three stooges is
if you're straight and you like them as
a child that you enjoy curly but then as
you mature you start to realize schempp
so ingeniousness Shemp is where it's at
yeah yeah are you still like them when I
was a kid my mom gets so mad at my dad
for letting me watch them she's a young
girl she shouldn't be watching my Ronnie
didn't you start yelling you know what I
forgot all about this I was working for
a producer who produced the Three
Stooges festival in burbank at the
Burbank Hilton or burbank whatever isn't
that like this weekend is it I think
it's this weekend oh you're kidding now
it all comes around Blaine it all comes
around this is comes around this weekend
this is the Burbank Hilton cell Milton
Milton stewed to huge begin in 99 and
never been i'm like a i'd love to go why
not so i took my girlfriend with me i
swear to god i was he only their guide
there with a date everybody everybody
was dressed like The Three Stooges we're
the only ones dressed normal they all
kind of gave me that weird girl girl
girl girl the only other girl here's got
a bald cap on it's just a lot of women
that look like Larry oh she's fine oh
you know what there was there was one
summer there was one summer that the
stooges were on every spit like every
day for a half an hour and I just
remember being home and I watched him
every day I saw him until they went they
reran a bunch of times I was like wow I
was it was really good i did my stooge
time all in that summer I loved him I
appreciated him now I don't have any
hatred of the Stooges you gotta let go
your hatred Joe what's not i mean hatred
is just energy you could be using on
yourself for something else cursed like
hating stuff [ __ ] I don't know I put
my hatred into the universe and the
universe takes my hate and aims it at
people know why there's would you know
it would see you Jen Kirkman CD cell
culture I don't think he'll that it'll
help into flights I should write a book
called Joe help
I don't know it just make you angry at
me I don't know if this is true but I
heard a rumor that Bill Cosby bought the
rights to the little rascals which
always accompanied Three Stooges and
will never air it because he thinks that
it the stereotypes of luck we stymie and
all that stuff yeah that's pretty balls
out I'd like to do that miss my eyes
that you had a lot of money to buy stuff
you hate and take it off here see you
later suddenly Susan is like Ted Koppel
what happened to arles heat race at
blaine capatch is apart you know our
four seasons I worked thanks I was I was
walking the picket line in front of
Warner Brothers Writers Guild at this
point still on strike let's drank and uh
sell adarna and I was walking with Adam
small who was a producer on mad tv and
he and facts bar produce a lot of comedy
shows blue-collar TV Luka Jamie Kennedy
experiment what does that kind of stuff
and he was telling me that they were
working on a show with Bill Cosby this
is my all be you know [ __ ] on my
part it is i'm making it all up that
they were doing the sketch show with
Bill Cosby where they were turning his
routines in two sketches they had a
sketch players at Cosby picked and he
was in charge of it they gave them he
gave them the rights to all of his
material and they were going to just
turn it into little sketches and stuff
and I think the network was like nobody
knows who caused because he's too old
wow I know somebody's too old actually
Jack occasion went to see him a couple
of years ago alive and he did the
dentist bit like you know like it was
McCartney doing you know the long and
wifey yeah exactly all the Vice couple
did he notice an encore uh I don't
remember i wasn't i don't remember the
details but the design felt sunday cuz
he's still motoring about even though
his shows you teen years off you he
retired as material like the 20 years he
did some like yeah never again they're
all he said for the last time on HBO
affairs right okay good commentary again
last week and we'll for the next 20
years ms you know no the the first
concert I ever saw when I was a kid was
Bill Cosby my
my my friend Tracy Smith and I used to
do Cosby routines in class and our moms
got together and they he played the york
fair and we SAT front row center at the
york fair grounds I must have been like
11 or 12 years old and I knew all of his
stuff by heart i would lip-sync in the
basement I just knew everything and he
I'll never forget he came out and he sat
down and he he just started talking he
started talking and then like a half an
hour later I was like oh my God he's
done seven of these classic bits and it
just sounded like he was just talking it
was just mind-blowing it just sounded
like a conversation and there was all
that stuff in it it was so he was so
engaging I'll never forget it is that
when you knew that you wanted to be a
comedian what's that supposed to mean ah
no you know I my parents took me to see
red skelton when I was a little kid will
not took me but they went to my parents
and their friends the geroons oh yeah
backer people wore ties and dresses and
things bola keys mrs. Gervin yes the
bottle this [ __ ] is cooking mmm this is
it longs park in lancaster pennsylvania
and it was big outdoor amphitheater
thing and i was like four years old and
i couldn't i remember i couldn't see red
Skelton's out there doing whatever and I
couldn't see so I just went up and sat
on the stage with my feet hanging off
and just was sitting there looking
because I wanted to see the show I just
thought I'll go and sit on the stage be
a good view and uh and I remember he at
one point red came over and he leans
over and he says if I said something to
me he's got the clown on or whatever
like I don't know what I said and the
crowd laughs and then he says something
else any and the crowd laughs and then
he leans down and he Pat's me on the
head and at that point my mom comes up
she's like here I'll take him and takes
it just my mom they were looking for me
but I was sitting on stage is that on
your resume no pinned or infrared scope
but you know what I just remember this
feeling that the crowd looking at me and
laughing and just thinking myself oh my
god I'm funnier than this [ __ ] guy
at four clowns really is that funny so
dumb I felt when I saw um so I felt when
it's gonna make a joke but I'm done by
choose not to oh so I felt when I saw
the unknown comic Murray Langston
mcmurray Langston my friend Suzanne her
dad played in a jazz band with him in
the Navy I've heard I heard Murray
Langston has the hose oh really a big P
he's got a got a big P you know it's
funny I think Huson it does but that's a
different conversation how we got that
one just hear you seen cuz it's his wife
that's just mean they got married like
three days later he's a huge penis she's
got it on stud yeah she's a babe a first
lady with a tongue stud yeah is just
good international policy oh yeah
workhorse got a strap on i think so jor
importantly doesn't own comic i want to
see the two of them walking around the
middle east and making peace oh yeah not
only can we see your hair in her face
her tongues got a piece of metal in it
oh yeah shall we get from the airport I
worked with a first of all i really
liked Marie Langston because his name
was Marie it was the only other Marie
Marie the Lang marie de la réalité all
them but I worked on the same way with
Joe Piscopo Jim Joe pissed Joe Piscopo
the the heavier you get the less funny
you are so keep that in mind I don't
know John Pinette what's that puts paid
on that doesn't know a good coin well
there's the exception to every rule Jack
and Zach and Mac me Oh dead dead from
comedy yeah Ralphie May Oh mark Rossi
you know Mark Rossi right you're from
Boston I don't legendary but you don't
work legendary FATCA yeah so fat how fat
was it wait did he sell little soaps
afterwards no easy you had no idea they
just looked little you know there was
there was a guy who did that that sounds
like his name he would sell little soaps
in Atlantic City no Wildwood New Jersey
because he had on holes it about how he
had a soap the little soaps from the
hotel they get second assassin anyone on
the water flume and guess what popped
out that little soap like he did it as a
long call back to it hey if you want to
bar soap afterwards I gotta back here
for $27
god I gotta sell the comedy would reckon
so oh I can sell fake buck teeth fake
buck to you why don't you just sell uh
go to the store and buy like a bunch of
coke cans and just sell them for a
dollar as long as you co can bit yeah
what I glass I guess used to sell just a
Xerox piece of paper and he'd sign it I
let people it's a doll are you [ __ ]
is do that I saw something i would i
would to buy a pizza from a photographer
what are you doing rich williams besides
destroying the sorry do trying to get us
it's easy to ated hear Mikey's legends
me too he's a double he's moonlighting
as a Foley Walker he's rhubari creaky
floor ceiling if you have a little piece
of soap stuck in your butt crack I'd the
Vic Dunlop eyeballs lodged in my ass he
sells those right yeah he also sells the
victim lop amputated diabetes feet oh
the hell is that we still 20 hey speak
did on Thanksgivings thanksgiving just
just came and went and I spent it at my
in-laws house watching speaking of
diabetes watching the bret michaels
dating reality show on vh1 rock of love
oh i never saw that oh god let me feel
so bad about myself and others but at
the end it's like he's you know he's got
diabetes bad what he does he does oh
yeah that's a big reveal you get me and
keeps to me to johnson love me love me
now i just think there was a wouldn't
who wouldn't know and sugar was his
poison Wow no you gotta write an article
the patella gosh i'm blogging that end
did he also sing pour some sugar on me
no that was that weapon they lost an arm
so what does that mean they should have
lost their hearing that would have been
Devon day long they lost their an arm
and like three other guys to guys to
guys yeah you know my hometown of York
Pennsylvania is a very heavy metal town
and somebody spray-painted def leppard
on an overpass on the 83
and but they misspelled def leppard I
spelling it correctly Oh like TM no
leopardi the most the smart is stupidest
thing about the upper I'm a huge fan and
a shitty speller I would have a great
speller in a way I don't know what I am
I remember watching the behind the music
on a great behind the music man death
drug abuse it's everything you wanted
behind the music but the lead singer was
yelling you know we started all the long
hair in the hairspray and in the role
that all the 80s rocketing like that's
like saying you out better aids yeah
that's like OJ's if I did it didn't kill
these two people you know if he would
have been in prison for killing those
two people this whole hotel invasion
thing would have an exam I hope he gets
like life I think it would just be great
it would be really trouble for sorry
okay you're charged with breaking and
entering you get the death penalty oh
yeah I just loved when CNN breaks away
from somebody talking about martial law
in Pakistan so then go to live coverage
of the trial of OJ and and the best
thing was a [ __ ] went out on the air on
CNN cuz was the sports Oh Lecter guy he
was saying well he said grab all this
[ __ ] and it went out just like a CNN
you're not gonna get in trouble for that
or yep CC no of course not it's
educational man we were so going so able
to swear and cuss on TV and then all of
a sudden did you just can't do it
anymore you know I mean everybody swears
and I it's it's it's one of those cases
where you're not allowed to talk about
what everybody it's like you're not my
friend mark voice said in comedy you're
not allowed to talk about pissing
[ __ ] and [ __ ] me what everybody
does you have to do it well not [ __ ]
but everybody does anyway the things
you're not allowed the things that
everybody have in common or what you're
not allowed to talk about in the same
thing with it's this weird i don't know
where i'm going with us this weird
denial of the fact take everybody says
[ __ ] you know you stub your toe [ __ ] god
damn it yeah yeah it's oh I've never
clutch my pearls and feito somebody said
[ __ ] well you know what's so upsetting
about that is that words just
they a meaning so that if I say
something Joe you can understand what
I'm saying when these uptight people say
fudge instead of [ __ ] they're saying
[ __ ] yeah it makes the same thing it's a
farce dirty yeah but when you say [ __ ]
you're saying fudge that's right by the
way of soon as we wrap this up I'm gonna
go fudge my wife really well what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go do my wife up the
[ __ ] tunnel I'm gonna pack some [ __ ] I'm
just gonna blow dry this mixing board
let me into your baby came I have a move
on the plane about masturbation and I
don't know if it's cuz im a girl or
whatever but when I do it on the rude
people get really quiet and I have to
stop in a funny way I make a joke like
women have been masturbating for five
years now you know like a stupid but I
have to be like it's okay and then
they're like oh ok ok ok and I still
don't know why they get so uptight at
first like it must be a girl thing
cousin the guys always talk about
everyone's fine but I have to go into
this thing of how it gets not gross and
if you're picturing it like picture this
instead and hang on and this it's like
comma I'm sorry being introduced as a
comedian no I well at times yeah yeah
but i usually do young people right that
I go on some other podcasts around town
and they spell it en any jen kirkman
comedian on this podcast oh I know the
comedian yeah and by the way uh yeah
you're banned from read stories you
can't do any other kind of yeah and your
road from band stories I mean some
exclusive shoot oh oh that's some effed
up s haha yeah yeah I heard some guy say
dude that is some effin [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's pretty funny you just said [ __ ]
[ __ ] up well I didn't go effing on the
first [ __ ] that's bull I think effins
just a word now oh yeah I like effing
it's pretty good a good word effing is
what people say when they
when they have a streaked hair and they
do shooters that's f'n Wow in high five
yeah it was kind of people it's that I
think Howard Stern made effing cool
because i am a fan and listen him and he
you know he had to say F and effing
during his last year's on terrestrial
radio and it sounds kind of cool when he
says it f that man but that's my heart
certain impression pretty good post
maybe cuz i was like he was another look
great richmond you're on stern room you
were i was on a long time ago was he
great no no I just got bashed I saw this
time you should have brought that up you
went on during his main years it was
really very first and you failed a test
that you really needed to pass from
school look I had taken this time
management seminar uh and it actually
wait a minute how do you get from a time
baby it's very exact turns out oh really
I'm like where we are all wrong I woke
up in this hotel room in Atlantic City
right I met Tony Robbins no I was a
headhunter for computer programmers and
I just started doing stand-up and I
looked like Bill Clinton so I started
getting a bunch of work as that when I
went to this time management seminar it
said write down one thing you want to do
in the next year that you're too afraid
to do and I said send a tape of my Clint
impression to be on stern in six months
I was on stern it was just a bunch of
events pulled together I was on with the
ex drummer from Guns and Roses who had
been kicked out because he did too many
drugs ah no bets McClure no it's messy
or Adler Oh Matt Sorum replacing yeah
okay and so I went on their addresses
Clinton with all these porn stars and we
were just distractions so that Stern
couldn't delve too much in this guy's
life and the guy had me reading off
people he wanted to thank as Clinton so
as soon as I walk in stearns going ah
your look like oh that's so creepy and
weird and I was just doing it to you
know so I could get time to build up my
act and I didn't I started reading it
off Stern thought I was doing plugs and
he's I'm gonna chop your [ __ ] head
off throw you out the window don't read
plugs and I didn't want a break
character and just be myself because I
didn't want to disappoint steven adler
the drummer who got kicked out of gutter
Oh funny so she's like holy fall because
he would have walked out of the studio
and killed him yeah exactly fleshing I
want to piss off a guy with the good
drugs yeah in the room come on people no
i squander my god then I got my own
blonde up and kirkman I remember her
she's on a comedy scene in the 2000s
that's my mnemonic device klonopin
Kirkman okk aur kaise you know my trick
to flying is I smoke as much pot in the
car on the way to the airport so you can
oh well done oh my god and I don't fly
with it pot makes me a panic attack so
that would not work for me you know it
caught it calms me it calms me down my
drink is I smoke as much pot on the way
to the airport then I forget where I'm
going go back home I sit the back of my
car go man where's the cab driver I took
I was a pot in high school and college
years and stuff like that and then I
took like seven years off and in those
seven years marijuana became so powerful
that if I take one hit I'm reduced to
tears and paranoia and I have to go home
I'm sure that's a case yeah it's
horrible yeah it's drag yeah yeah I
could have a way to bear ain't that one
hit wonder [ __ ] yeah it's so so
effective horrible yeah sure if it's
organic I see people like these medical
marijuana sea ice is Liam Payne lose
that they're inhaling oh yeah those are
those are those are vaporizers volcano
vida there's a mess it's it's it's like
a it's a bag and you you did you put pot
in a thing and then we'll heat it talk
yeah I mean I'm going somewhere good
with this believe me oh no I'm ready to
buy along here in Ferguson enjoy like
really hot air it like it almost bakes
it or dry roast it and it was it
vaporizes ta to study into this bag and
then you inhale what's in the bag and
it's like it's like smoke free smoke and
it's all THC and it's not bad for your
lung--it's the healthiest way to smoke
pot because it doesn't burn it is you so
effen hi it gets you noticed I'm mighty
in F and hot in evident I took a hit off
of paper I had a party and I took a hit
off a vaporizer a half hour later I
kicked everybody out threw up and went
to bed
yeah that's why don't realize even my
house I know why people love vaporizers
they love to throw up here's where I was
going with that we have the bag for oh
here's where I was going with that
that's too much effort to smoke pot if
somebody goes hey uh do you have a pipe
or papers you go well I know but I can
hollow out it you know what forget it
i'll have a drink yeah i forget it i
won't have anything I'll have some
coffee I don't need to get high that bad
but turrets really hard to find people
actually smoke anymore because the
vaporizers are really the in with the
end kids just think it looks so crazy
I've been to a party where people pull
them out I'm like really like a small
yeah like adult little like the
caterpillar from alice in wonder yeah
people are very Tom any video that
spooked Alice in Wonderland I don't know
I start judging i start judging going
you can't dependent you are on this like
boring meat is very too much trouble you
know I weeks you have so much you got to
take a klonopin for happened drink come
ya drinkin ceramic monofin start judging
me don't go home no and no one smokes
weed and the comedy scenes / the least
popular drug oh yeah really no I think
I'm the only us three are the only three
you don't you know there's yeah drug
business there's a bad coke resurgence
going on there is in a comedy second a
mile the Nerds I know we know oh yeah I
did it oh right yes it's bad you know
what it's it's a can't I can't believe
the people that that that say that they
know comedy that know how comedy was in
the 80s and see how sweaty and disguise
so order their shirts no Boggs comedy
tonight you know just you look
ridiculous like that movie when stand up
stood out the Boston comedy so yeah
everybody saw lomita yeah everybody's so
sweaty Cook is a bad drug it's confident
about this about the 00 just me oh sorry
the only one like everyone has that same
kind of joke but super confident about
it I i keep my drug used to myself
except when i talk about it on a podcast
you know i think i did coke once at a
party at the comedy factory outlet
christmas party in philadelphia this is
back
the comedy factory a comic factory
outlet there were two cops CFO oh there
was one if there was one in Philly and
there was one in Baltimore and I was on
the floor staff in Baltimore they would
they would have the staff be comedian so
that if somebody didn't show up they
could put comedians on it was good but
we went to this party at the one in
Philly we rented a van and I remember I
was I was smoking pot I was really drunk
and I was on acid what I'm having a
great time at this weird old place I
just it's Christmas in Philadelphia and
off with a klonopin yeah like I'm like
22 years old this is it's incredible I'm
just what's going on and uh and this one
comic came out and he had a little coke
spoon little thing will vile whatever he
wasn't nobody was doing lines but we're
all standing out in alley we're smoking
a joint and this is of course after the
statute of limitations has gone on the
story people a little thing a lot of
people are getting busted off podcast
Lucy a little apt a little snort of it
just a little tiny thing of it and it
killed everybody I had every buzz I had
and I never and I kept drinking and I
couldn't get any couldn't get drunk it
was like I'll never do coke again that
might have been the acid though not was
really cuz everybody's don't blame the
Assam what I used to do acid I remember
not like once you level off on acid
there's no you can just chow as much
asset as you want you're not gonna get
any more [ __ ] up oh god I've never
done acid I'm too afraid I don't do acid
my friend is my mine this was back you
know was touring with fish weren't you
the string cheese incident I don't mean
the band I mean the string cheese
incident Philadelphia and yeah that was
a lot of people dog right and the big
lizard came out Nate George oh man who
was that list I read for that read for
the part of the lizard in my acid trip
oh man all right any uh well any plugs
before we go wrap this thing up and he
jen kirkman CD self-help you can get at
iTunes and you can go to my myspace page
myspace.com / jen kirkman one end on the
gin please thank you how many Inns in
comedian 14 okay and also hit her up for
klonopin when you see her at UCP how
many ends
Donovan how many ends of my holding up
Jen not enough there's no ends in
klonopin you missed my great facial when
does this error um january january Oh
Jane you are okay I don't know how many
plans yet so I can't announce anything
okay rich williams work in around town
going on the road uh actually i'm full
time focusing on my blue collar calm all
right yes ordered with Funny or Die and
producing zefiro is the one comedy site
that's not going under miss money or
done yeah exactly everybody else is gone
under we're partnered with tony hawk's
site too and so I didn't know we did a
spoof called Tony Hawking skateboarding
super genius Stephen Hawking basically
in a wheelchair he does a faceplant
that's all living in alley we actually
have a weird blue color I write for
building ball you produce blue color TV
I think if Emil dollar for a couple
seasons Jenna and I'm from a blue-collar
family me too yeah mama jo Wilson bring
blue calor expression of distaste and
surprised at the same time anything
anything coming up bullying after the
strike uh no I think I'll be uh I think
I'll be a free agent yeah Oh God in 2008
I hope all right you're the what
according to the Chinese oh good
question the ant [ __ ] other no I hope he
doesn't see the video during my at my
set you know I'm just you know under
everybody's gay with hair plugs for 2008
I'm just gonna try to do stand-up and
I'm playing an abandoned having fun oh
ya go what is it the Voodoo Brooklyn
souls at Tulsa skull swingers we all
depressive masks anything less goes no
punk band it's all 60s garage that's
awesome and what about Luke of a boom I
want to talk to you about that doll you
have to come back and talk about that
that's sure lucha vavoom our next one is
in February for Valentine's Day at the
Mayan theater in los angeles Mexican
wrestling you burlesque I love that
producer Katt Williams you know cat from
MTV on Rodriguez cat Rodriguez that's it
Katt Williams feeding cat William it's
okay
she and I have a black guy mullet she
was a ring girl friend yes Israel over
there she's awesome she's over at MTV
Joe Wilson is always at myspace /a Olsen
comedy calm me every week on dork forest
start first radio.com yeah we're now so
we're not going to plug any more
podcasts on the show I decided channel
okay I'm sorry oh well Martha Kelly's
Martha Martha's car belong oh that's a
great as car honey it's really funny the
second one maybe it's up right now I
don't want to be up by the time this
thing goes up where else what if one of
us dies by the time this airs don't say
that i always think of that [ __ ] now
it's gonna be me man when you flying
again jittery friday and then two weeks
after that oh it's fine it's fine after
that look for my new self no but I've
done I've had a great life and I'm you
know what's my house is in order yeah
John how do you want to be remembered
what's good that's compatible tape right
now no no no I'm not going into them I
thought I know we can put our hands
together right now and we can call up
the career of Bobby Collins speaking of
a dead comedian yeah I thought I was
dying once and to your point of I've had
a good life I wrote out a letter as i
was driving myself to the emergency room
it was just a big panic attack i have
sleep apnea I'm vertigo and all this
stupid [ __ ] but I wrote please contact
my cousin Judy my ex girlfriend for
about the dogs and hopefully nobody will
have to find this but I did the best job
I could i wish you gotten a car accident
cuz you were writing wailing forbidden
those you texting texing' a rear end of
the garbage writer chick that what
Britain been yours is doing all the time
yeah I suck why are you buying knife
then Williams dies in the Williams
family comes millionaires for like
Hallmark cards yeah the best death is
just a big fake holiday by the death PA
and homework hey thanks a lot this is a
lot of fun you guys this is a really
good time hope we can have everybody
back
lonegan season two and we don't think
everybody we're listening we've got
really good reviews and all the great
stuff said different comedy sites in the
regular intercom if you're not there
already and we'll talk to you soon
thanks bye